let's start with uh why you're poor
um it's funny because whenever i do
these shows i often like do some
searches and it's like okay let's see
what shows up on google let's see what's
on youtube and there's some funny [ __ ]
like because you spend too much money on
starbucks coffee
because you don't have a budget
because um
you don't have a rainy day fund with
three months of your earnings you know
set aside okay that's like basic bit
[ __ ] you know for being honest that's
like very entry level sort of stuff
i'm gonna go through something through
some items that are a little more
complex um
higher paid grade stuff if you will
now
let me start with limiting beliefs so
i've always been a car guy you guys
should know this by now if you've been
watching my channel
i like fast [ __ ] you know and when i was
um
about 15 16 i used to sit at the bus
stop take the bus a couple stops to go
to my job i used to work at this nursery
called white rose
and um you know often just [ __ ]
hauling around heavy [ __ ] pete moss in
people's cars five foot park benches
patio furniture working in in the
greenhouse stuff like that
and sitting in sitting at the bus stop
i'd be sitting there watching the cars
go by and i'm basically car shopping i'm
just looking at [ __ ] that's going on the
car that caught my eye at that time
which i had a limiting belief that i
thought that i could not afford ever in
my entire life was a 1988 iraq
convertible
uh chevrolet carr um iraq just stood for
international race of champions at the
time a lot of guys make fun of it they
would use the acronym they'd say italian
[ __ ] out cruising ireek of cologne um
there was always like the ford versus
chevy sort of that caught me back and
forth but i had this limiting belief at
the time that that car is beyond my
reach i would never have it it's
beautiful and i want to have one i did
end up buying that car
six years later
um
it was not beyond my reach another
item that i thought was beyond my reach
before i bought that iroc was a katana
600 um motorcycle
um that cost me 5 500 when i bought it
and the time when i bought i think i was
18. um again with my own money i worked
i you know i put in the time saved it up
sort of thing and by the way i was
paying rent to my uh parents
from the age of like 15 16 on or
something like that
um not a huge amount but enough where is
like holy [ __ ] my friends are like
you're actually paying rent to your
parents what the [ __ ] you know they
still give me an allowance but that was
me right um i had limiting beliefs that
said that that was like this glass
ceiling is something that i can't push
beyond
so i went from you know um the iraq to
some japanese cars i had a subaru wrx
which seemed like you know glass ceiling
for me i paid about twenty twenty two
thousand for that
um then i went to some german cars m3
audi s4s um
three convertible i had an m5 dine in
tune
then i started going into the exotics
the r8s and now the mclaren and every
single
item that i that i move from from from
from that 5500 katana all the way up to
a 300 000 mclaren
i was thinking to myself there's there's
nothing beyond this you know if i get to
this i can't do any better that's how
that's how the human brain thinks okay
it thinks from the perspective of
you can't do this and it then
establishes a limiting belief in your
head and then prevents you from going
further than that and i smash through
every single one of those glass ceilings
right
driving more
interesting fun impressive cars um you
know to the point now where it's like i
go somewhere and kids are coming up to
me you know when i say kids i'm using
the term lucy like 19 20 21 year olds
young men let's say
come up to me and they're like
well what do you guys do like how do you
guys afford that like i'm like i'm poor
how do i get to like how do i do that i
want that over there and i'm going to
talk about the ways that you can make
some serious money so the first thing
that's holding you back in your limiting
beliefs and why you're poor is because
you actually think that that is who you
are
and
when you stop believing that you're a
loser you're going to stop being a loser
if you stop believing that you're
scrawny and unattractive you're going to
stop being swanny and unattractive
you're going to jim you're going to pick
up weights you're going to lift heavy
[ __ ] put it down you're going to eat
properly you're going to sleep rest and
repeat and you're going to do that for
years until you start to develop a
strong masculine frame and put some
muscle on so you don't look like a twerp
all of these limiting beliefs that that
guys have in all areas of life whether
it comes to money muscles uh dealing
with women being captivating all that
sort of stuff
are beliefs that you can smash through
for the most part
uh money is certainly one of them um
again
people [ __ ] on me routinely oh you're
you're totally out of touch who is this
guy that thinks that you should be a
millionaire by the time you're 30 or at
the very least 40. you most people can't
accomplish that he's hanging around with
high rollers and his his head's in the
clouds blah blah [ __ ] blah dude i was
poor i had nothing to show for myself i
was paying rent as a teenager and a 600
cc motorcycle to me
at 18 seem like a rolls-royce okay
when you stop telling yourself these
[ __ ] lies that you can't be
successful you can't make money or that
money is evil that's another one you
know a lot of a lot of narratives that
guys have heard through their younger
years especially usually if they've been
raised you know in a household by a
single parent usually a single mom is
that you know money is evil and people
that have money are evil people and they
accumulate it through deceptive means
sort of things like that and nothing can
be further from the truth all that money
is is it's a store of value
and it is and the more you've
accumulated generally speaking the more
value you've created in the world not
always true but generally speaking the
more value you've created in the world i
mean the reason why um the richest guy
in the world and he keeps flip-flopping
back and forth between who knows who
elon musk jeff bezos whatever the reason
why keeps flip-flopping back and forth
is because those positions keep changing
but
the reason why these guys have so much
wealth is because they created an online
marketplace like amazon where you can
buy virtually anything ship it around
the world and get it literally the next
day in most parts of the world urbanized
parts of the world um elon musk electric
cars rockets solar panels okay these
guys solve problems big problems and
they become um
you know big time rich sort of thing you
know billionaire sort of thing so
when you start blowing past limiting
beliefs that hold you back then you
start getting into serious money
so the first thing you got to do is
smash through limiting beliefs
the next thing that i've seen a lot of
as well is people overthink instead of
take action
um i see this in
my one-on-one coaching sessions i see it
in group zoom sessions that i've done
where it's like
it is [ __ ] simple it is very very
very very very you know it's the same
thing with chicks when i say to guys
like if you just avoid women that bring
red flags to the table daddy issues
feminists unhappy unlucky uh she tries
to compete with you men uh you know she
deals with men from her past she's got
ex-boyfriends in her lives you know she
sucks with money she's got loads of debt
she's violent she has extreme jealousy
she's a party girl loads of tattoos and
piercings big notch counts single moms
seeking validation online sugar babies
uh pathological liars baby rabies hissy
fits uh not not being in control of the
birth drama queens and addictive type of
personalities if you avoid all of these
20 red flags your life will generally be
very simple and pleasant with women
all you have to do is avoid this now
that's not just it obviously but that's
a big part of it you've got to you know
you've got to understand what women
respond to you've got to say no you
can't go through beta site betatization
through a thousand concessions if you're
newer to the channel read the damn book
okay it's on amazon the unplugged alpha
it's always pinned above at the end of
the show but
over thinking instead of taking action
for most guys
becomes very very problematic and if you
just deal with like the simplicity the
basics
of life
and avoid complicating it unnecessarily
then taking action is far far better
than sitting around tweeting your thumbs
going i got to think about this a little
bit more i'm not really sure
like one of the things that one of my
great mentors once said to me was
you know in the absence of clarity do
something just [ __ ] move find a
direction and move in it maybe you bang
up against the wall and it's an
immovable object you can dig around it
you can go around it you can go over it
you can maybe leverage it move it out of
the way
you know sort of thing but sometimes you
bang up against [ __ ] okay that's that's
fine you know be like a roomba vacuum
robot bounce off that object and kind of
move in another direction the point that
i'm making though is
most guys don't take action they just
overthink [ __ ] hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you